une autre télé copies envoyées à deux
jours de la primaire démocrate et du
haut de ses 75 ans ronnie scott n'arrête
jamais depuis 35 ans avec de reckoning
crew son équipe de bénévoles qui offrent
des services communautaires et le
carbure à la politique c'est ok il n'a
jamais caché sa préférence démocrate au
fil du temps et des présidents cette
fois ci est pour elle et pour ses
fidèles compagnes joe biden est l'homme
de la situation
bernis sillonne donc la région jour
après jour pour convaincre les électeurs
de voter pour son candidat
mais elle avoue ses premiers choix
c'était kamala harris la seule femme
noire dans la course mais qui a
abandonné depuis quelques jours la
récolte de sympathisants de l'ancien
vice-président est plutôt bonne pour
l'équipe de bernis leur travail est
essentiel pour joe biden car la majorité
des électeurs démocrates de la caroline
du sud sont afro américains mobiliser le
vote noir c'est aussi le credo de black
vaughters qui veut sensibiliser les
afro-américains à l'importance de leur
choix
de l'amour et du pouvoir prêche cliff
albright pour ne plus avoir peur de
voter
pour lui voter c'est aussi lutter contre
la restriction du droit de vote des
noirs et se battre pour la réforme de la
justice à ces seules des candidats plus
progressistes comme bernie sanders où il
habite warren pourrait faire la
différence cette fois-ci selon blacks de
l'équipe de bernis elle a fait ses
calculs
biden devrait gagner samedi face à
bernie sanders et si jamais leurs jo
n'est pas investi comme candidat
démocrate alors leur mission reste la
même se débarrasser de celui qu'elle ne
nomme jamais le 45e président et d'ici
novembre
elle ne compteront donc ni leur temps ni
leur énergie pour y arriver ici frédéric
arnould radio-canada hopkins en caroline
du sud